[music playing]
- It's just a really tight-knit
ocean-loving community.
Everybody generally has the same
sort of healthy ocean lifestyle
vibe.
That's what makes
this area so unique.
- Scott Bass has called San
Diego home for over 40 years.
- I love living here.
You're so close to
what really amounts
to the largest national
park that we have,
which is the Pacific Ocean.
It provides a lot
of fulfillment.
- San Diego is a coastal oasis
for its beautiful shoreline
and marine wildlife.
Just below the surface is a
coastal view of iconic animals,
like the California sea
lion and the official state
marine fish, the
hard-to-miss Garibaldi.
But sitting atop the
food chain are sharks.
Historically, interactions
between sharks and humans
are rare.
But in 2008, a horrifying
incident occurs.
- There was a lot of disbelief.
This hadn't happened in
San Diego in over 50 years.
It was a sad day.
It felt like summertime.
It was a beautiful
San Diego day.
- In the early
morning, Scott Bass
was paddleboarding along
Fletcher Cove, about 15 miles
north of the city of San Diego.
He's near a group of
triathletes in training.
Among them is retired
veterinarian Dr. Dave Martin.
- Dr. Martin was swimming
with his triathlete group.
They were approximately 150
yards off of the surf line.
- But somewhere below the
group, a predator takes aim.
[loud bang]
A shark sinks its teeth
into Dr. Martin's legs
and launches him
out of the water.
He screams for help.
- Help!
- Everyone in the
water is stunned.
- It was very surreal.
People were scared.
- Dr. Martin
disappears underwater.
Finally, the shark
releases its hold,
and the group pulls Dr.
Martin back to shore.
First responders
race into action.
[helicopter rotor blades]
- I remember the helicopter
came right above me
and just boomed down on me,
"There's been a shark attack.
Please get out of the
water immediately."
- But for Dr. Martin,
the injuries to his legs
are too severe.
Before he can be
transported to a hospital,
he succumbs to his injuries.
The tragedy captures the
attention of Southern
California residents.
- There was a lot
of police there.
There was a lot of media there.
There was a lot of shock.
There was a lot of sadness.
There was a lot of despair.
- And news outlets
cover it worldwide.
- You know, it's a big deal.
You know, there hasn't
been a shark attack--
a fatal shark attack in
San Diego in something
like 50 years.
- Residents are stunned.
Since 1970, the area has
averaged about one attack
every three years.
But Dr. Martin's
fatal incident in 2008
is just the harbinger
of things to come.
In 2009, a sudden
spike takes hold, six
attacks in only seven months.
- I'm sure any number of
parents were concerned.
People were trying
to figure it out.
[music playing]